all right let's do this I have a story
for you today about the unmitigated
control that large media and social
media platforms have over the content
you see when it comes to news no matter
what your intentions are and I'll
explain that in a second it's been
months since I've come to you about a
problem on our various platforms because
things have actually been going okay for
the last couple of months in fact this
week was one of our best weeks for the
David Pakman show in one sense but it
also has very quickly become one of the
worst CNN filed a completely bogus
fraudulent claim against our coverage of
day one of the Trump impeachment inquiry
and Facebook has completely shut down
our monetization of videos and I mean
like literally to $0.00 with no
explanation or prior notice I'll explain
it to you and I believe you are going to
be shocked and appalled by this so we've
had a great week going right on Tuesday
our YouTube channel had about a million
views just that one day it was our best
day of the year in terms of views
normally we get 9 to 11 million views a
month so one day with a million views is
a really great day in fact our best day
of the year
Wednesday is going great we do the six
hour livestream of the Trump impeachment
inquiry as many of you know House
proceedings are public domain made
available by the House of Representative
video feeds and by c-span so our six
hour stream yesterday which we spent all
day producing was using the house feed
and the c-span feed no copyright issues
we're not using content from CNN or Fox
News or anything like that we're in the
clear the live stream ends we put up the
video of the archive of that six hour
stream so people can go back and check
out our commentary we do that in
addition to our one hour show and our
member show within a few minutes I get a
notification that cNN has filed a claim
against our video which is on screen
right now for our television audience
and I say wait wait a second CNN we
didn't use any CNN video we use the feed
from the House of Representatives and
from c-span why on earth is CNN filing a
copyright claim against me for something
that has none
of their content we spent six hours on
this and then CNN takes it down
and we go to YouTube and the videos
visibility is totally off and of course
monetization is off so not only and we
not make money from a six hour stream we
spent all day producing because of a
bogus claim by CNN but the videos not
even visible not making money would be
one thing but the entire video was made
invisible this should be against the law
to file fraudulent copyright claims by
the morning now by this morning after I
appealed it emailed people at CNN they
have removed the claim with no
explanation for why would CNN claim a
video that doesn't have any of their
content they got away with it the video
made no money during those key hours
after being published sickening but it
got even worse more than a year ago I
think it was September of 2018 I was
notified by Facebook hey listen great
news you've been uploading your videos
to your Facebook page for a long time
you can now monetize your videos so we
were thrilled because we had this great
potential for facebook video
monetization to be a new revenue source
we've had YouTube monetization issues
now we can monetize on Facebook and
maybe even it out a little bit but sadly
it didn't work out so well because we
were monetizing starting in in 2018 but
sometimes we would make seven dollars in
a month from monetizing Facebook video
or $25 the next month sadly it sort of
fell flat based on what we were hoping
for but then suddenly three months ago
Facebook monetization starts becoming a
real thing we actually start making some
real money that's important for the show
by monetizing on Facebook and it's some
new revenue potential for us what
fantastic news and a few days ago I go
on and I notice we're back down to like
we made a dollar we made 50 cents we
made zero dollars and zero cents on
Facebook despite uploading all of our
videos there what the hell happened they
never contacted me about any issue we've
been uploading our videos the videos are
getting views so what's going on
I click around our control panel on
Facebook yesterday and notice this
big red exclamation point that says
restricted monetization the David Pakman
show
shared content that was removed by
Facebook for going against community
standards on November 6 2019 they
claimed that they notified us on that
date of what video violated their
standards I can assure you we were not
notified on Facebook I didn't get an
email no email went to my spam folder I
tried to look into this I try to contact
someone which Facebook of course makes
impossible to do contact support nothing
contact ad team nothing
contact anyone nothing the one thing I
can do is submit an appeal which I do
and within hours I get a message back
saying thank you for submitting an
appeal after taking a look we've decided
to temporarily suspend monetization
because your page goes against our
policies they of course don't tell me
anything about why or what violated
their policies or which page it was of
course understand we do an FCC safe show
with no profanity gore or anything like
that
understand the insanity of white
supremacist content is being spread on
Facebook Mark Zuckerberg is in front of
Congress saying we don't fact-check ads
we don't do this we don't do that we are
as hands-off as we can be and they shut
off monetization for the David Pakman
show an FCC safe show and we're the
problem we are the ones sharing the
problematic content of course I tried
writing right back to Facebook's bogus
letter and I got an automatic replying
saying oh this case is closed no one
will see a response feel free to file
another appeal so listen this is
supposed to be when shows like ours
start to flourish
it's the 365 days before an election
historically these are the best moments
for us now in the immediate if you have
a contact like a real person at Facebook
that you know in the ad side in the
monetization side in the video side any
real person you can put me in touch with
it would be more than greatly
appreciated if you did that um audience
wise we're growing quickly we've added
like 3,000 YouTube
subscribers in the last five days or
something like that but we are getting
hit with this stuff everywhere so I'm
not gonna make a big pitch this is
really about the way in which these
platforms are controlling what you
ultimately get to see in support but
consider grabbing a membership on our
website no one can shut that down
there's no copyright claims there's no D
monetization it's just you sign up at
join pakman.com we pay a 2.9 percent fee
for processing your payment and we keep
the rest okay
very much appreciated we have a coupon
code the code is half 19 it'll save you
50% I don't care at what price you sign
up use the coupon code don't you can
save 50 percent with the coupon code
half 19 this is how we grow our base of
support you know in a real grassroots
way with small contributions also if
it's easier for you or if you prefer you
can pledge on patreon at patreon.com
slash david pakman show this is a very
backward situation and I'm coming to you
laying out the full scope of it and it
is disturbing and it is disappointing